el grupo de los siete reitera su apoyo
Ucrania en el último día de la jornada
de la cumbre coincidieron en que
continuará su compromiso en brindar
asistencia diplomática financiera
humanitaria y militar a Ucrania y
reafirmaron su determinación de
restaurar la paz en Ucrania y mantener
el orden internacional la visita de
selensky buscó dar un mensaje de fuerza
y unión de los líderes para mantener el
orden internacional y reiterar su apoyo
cráneo dos países ausentes del g7 pero
que ocuparon las conversaciones del día
fueron Rusia y China cuando se le
preguntó el Primer Ministro de Japón
fumida sobre su rol con china aseguró
que trabajará en construir una relación
estable basada en el diálogo para
trabajar en los retos internacionales
también hizo énfasis en que Hiroshima
fue la oportunidad para mostrarle a los
líderes las consecuencias de una bomba
atómica nuevamente vimos las principales
avenidas de la ciudad cerradas y repleta
de oficiales para
garantizar la seguridad durante la
visita de los líderes de los países más
poderosos del mundo en el museo de la
paz en los alrededores se observaban
pancartas de civiles pidiéndole a China
y a Rusia Que retiren su apoyo las
continuas actividades de Corea del Norte
y en contra de la Cumbre del g7 tras
catalogarla de imperialista los
ciudadanos de una ciudad sobreviviente
del desastre nuclear Espera que la
Cumbre no se quede en acciones escritas
en un papel